♪ [music] ♪
- [male] We are the paradoxical ape, by
pedal, naked, large brain. Long the master
of fire, tools and language but still
trying to understand ourselves, aware that
death is inevitable yet filled with
optimism. We grow up slowly, we hand down
knowledge, we empathize and deceive, we
shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [David] Before we get to the question
and answer session, I'd like to say just a
few words about the range of things that
have come up in this symposium. As Roger
said at the beginning, we decided to make
our focus not how did language begin but
how did language come to have the form it
has and we've included some other things
that we think go along with that. One
thing that we've seen today is the
outstanding array of different types of
language that have either been studied in
some depth or mentioned in passing and
that have come up in this symposium. We
particularly wanted to include both spoken
and sign languages and take advantage of
the fact that sign languages, being so
much younger than spoken languages, afford
us a chance to see language at earlier
stages of its development, than we can get
very readily in spoken languages. We saw
that new linguistic forms emerge in spoken
language as well in Carmel O'Shannessy's
talk where we sew how children in this
Australian community have put together
bits and pieces of languages used around
them and created something entirely new.
There were references to pidgins and
creoles and other such newly arising types
of language as well as two brand new
languages like the Central Taurus Sign
Language and the Al Sayyid Bedouin sign
language in southern Israel. All of these
things there's such a wide range of
different types of language sprouting up
around us in different parts of the world
and offer us a chance to see languages at
the very earliest stages, yet we must keep
in mind that this is not the same thing as
what the earliest stages of human language
must have been like. For all of these are
languages spoken or signed by individuals
with modern human brains and that's
probably a very big difference, and the
last talks on language in the brain
provided three different perspectives on
what the brain is doing in use of language
or when the individual is doing linguistic
tasks as well as particularly in professor
Mayberry's talk. How exposure to language,
to any language, in the early years, the
earliest years of life is essential to
being able to fully master and acquire a
human language.
So with that I think I will conclude these
remarks and turn now to the questions that
you have written down and have been
collected.
- [Roger] So this is very exiting, as you
know we've just had nine wonderful talks
and we have way more than nine wonderful
questions but we'll do our best, we'll see
what we can get through. So the first
question of many many great questions. . .
thank you all for excellent questions
that you asked, this is for Ann Senghas.
The question is just sort of a merger of
several different questions, but the
general question is, “What was there
before the first cohort of Nicaraguan Sign
Language speakers, what was the setting in
which this emerged?” And also, “With
successive cohorts, what is the
relationship between the ability to
communicate between cohorts?” So is it the
case that successive cohorts are able to
communicate with their predecessors but
not vice-versa and could you give us more
information on that?
- [Ann] So the first question of what came
before, what did people have before. If
you meet deaf people in Nicaragua who are
over the age of 50, these are people who
were language-less in childhood right.
These are people who are the kind of
people that Rachel was talking about. But
some of them encountered the sign language
late in life and some of them did not. And
so, the people that I've met who preceded
that first cohort really range in their
ability to participate as members of the
society that these are people who were
language-less.
They vary in how much they developed a
home sign system that Ray Jackendoff
eluded to that these simple systems that
have some of the elements of language that
they might developed with their families
some deaf people develop those and some
people don't. So, they really are variable
unlike people who are exposed to language
who aren't variable they all kind of can
use their language. And then the ability
to communicate across cohorts is a really
interesting one, I have lots of fun videos
of that and the kinds of miscommunications
that can occur. But to give you a flavor
for it, it's kind of like interacting with
someone like if you're a younger signer
interacting with an older signer or
someone from an earlier cohort, think of
that, the younger signers are more
specific they mark things more
specifically, they make more distinctions
in their language. So some of those
distinctions aren't processed by the older
signers like if you're signing something
in one location versus another that
doesn't mean anything to an older signer.
So it's kind of like someone's speaking a
language without any of the morphology.
You can get a lot of stuff across, you can
use context they don't notice most of the
time that they're using different forms,
but when you push them on a really hard
task where you have to make a certain kind
of distinction with minimal pairs they. .
.the sense that seems ambiguous to an
older signer will be more specific to a
younger signer. It's kinda like talking to
a non-native speaker of English maybe or
if you have a grandmother who knows
Italian and you speak English with her and
her English isn't like yours but you don't
notice it most of the time, she's a late
learner of English and I think it feels
like that to them. The older signers think
the younger signers are kind of fast and
messy, and they're screwing the language
up and they make these signs that are
sloppy, and they drop certain important
things and they put the words in all these
funny orders where things get ambiguous.
- Thank you very much. So the next
question I'd like to. . . this is also a
merger of a couple of questions, this is
for Simon Kirby. So the question generally
is that “One thing that is not present in
the experiments that you reported is
social interaction between people, so this
is very single speaker, single generation
to next speaker, next generation and what
are your thoughts on. . . are there
important dimensions of the nature of
evolution of language that we can't
capture without that kind of social
interaction within generations?” So just
could you have a few comments on that?
- [Simon] That's a great question. So when
we started doing these experiments we were
just interested in this iterate learning
process and that first experiment I showed
you where we just ended up with just a
smaller and smaller number of words, and
in some cases get this incredibly
degenerate language which only has one
word for everything. That language is
amazingly learnable, it's very easy to
learn a language where you just say Ug
for everything. So we had to put in this
kind of hack into the experiment where we
filtered out those ambiguous items in sort
of secret between each generation. But of
course, there's a much more sensible way
of doing that which we've then gone on to
do which is to add in communication. So
the experiments that we're doing now in
Edinburgh nearly exclusively involve
interaction as well. So we have two
individuals who learn their language from
the previous generation and then interact
in some kind of communicative task and
then the output of that is fed on to the
next generation, and our current models
and experiments and our theory is that you
need both.
So you need learning which leads to
simplification of structure and you need
communication that leads to a pressure to
be expressive. And when there's this
pressure to be simple plus a pressure to
be expressive, that's the sweet spot that
gives you linguistic structure. So I think
it's really. . . linguistic structure is
the product of a kind of tug of war
between these two processes: wanting to be
expressive with your language but also the
language needing to be learn-able by the
next generation.
- Thank you, so the third question is for
Rachel Mayberry. The question is, “Have
you studied how the teenagers in your
sample who didn't have the exposure to
early language performed on non-linguistic
tasks?” So what's the relationship between
performance in linguistic and
non-linguistic tasks?
- [Rachel] Well, depends on what kind of
linguistic, non-linguistic task you're
talking about. They're very very good at
picture arrangement and so, the elements
of a story, putting them together they're
quite good at that. One of the teens is a
fantastic drawer, he just makes beautiful
drawings and paintings. Another of the
teens is fascinated with maps, they have
no problems navigating, driving, doing
tasks like this. Math skills are very very
low, reading they're illiterate. Those are
the language skills. But for the. . . and
we haven't really looked at a range of
non-linguistic tasks.
- Thank you, so the next question is for
David Perlmutter, I think this is a really
neat question. “How do sign languages
rhyme?”
- Well, this question obviously comes from
someone who's language is one where rhyme
is a prominent feature of poetry. As it
happens I actually published a paper on
poetry in sign language and one of the
questions I addressed. . . it's starts out
as an analysis in depth of one particular
poem and then I go on to discuss the
question of how do different languages
differ with respect to the resources they
put at the disposal of their poets? And in
particular when there's a difference in
modality between a spoken language and a
sign language, how do spoken and sign
languages differ in the resources they
give their poets for poetic expression?
And so, one of-- I don't talk about rhyme
as such but I analyze in depth the
structure of this particular poem and the
types, the ways the poet uses ASL for
poetic effects. And particularly uses of
resources that ASL puts at his disposal
that are quite unlike anything in spoken
language. Let me just say that I was
amazed at the richness and depth I
discovered in the one poem I analyzed in
detail, I can recite a poem in Russian, in
French, in German whatever. I cannot
recite a poem in ASL because things are
going on simultaneously with the hands,
the body, the face facial expressions.
And though I sign at a very elementary
level with deaf signers I simply can't do
all those things at once that are required
for poetic effects, that are used for
poetic effects in this particular poem. So
that's my answer. If you're interested, I
can tell you where to find this paper or
provide it to you if you're interested.
Come up and see me afterwards. All right
let's try another question to Ray
Jackendoff. “Why would languages ever
develop more complexity, embedding, etc?
If language evolves, what is the source of
pressure for them to become more complex,
i.e.beyond linear grammar?”
- [Ray] It's a good question that I've
asked my self about a lot, it actually
relates to David's answer to the last
question. So all of these strategies that
we have with agreement and tenses, and
relative clauses, and concessive clauses
and all this sort of thing give us extra
dimensions of expressivity that we can do
all at once. So instead of just saying
“boy kiss love girl” or something like
that, we can say, “Well, we're focusing on
what the boy is doing, he's kissing the
girl,” and that 'he love' is kind of
backgrounded and that's conveyed by
putting it in the relative clause. We can
make distinct-- and different languages
make different distinctions of what kinds
of things they express grammatically. So
some languages will have some little
operator on a verb that will tell you
whether you actually saw this event
yourself or somebody told you about it,
they're called evidentials.
They seem to be things that people want to
express and to do it in a linear language,
you have to say I know da, da, da and it's
more efficient in a way in expression to
just put it as a suffix. Now what I think
if this is right that linear languages
were sort of an earlier stage in evolution
of the human language capacity, it took
some extra tweak in the genetics to make
us capable of learning languages of this
more complex sort. Again, I don't have any
evidence to that. It's sort of a working
hypothesis in terms of which you can
reevaluate a lot of the things that we
have been studying over the years.
- Great. Thank you very much, so this is
another merger question to Edward Chang.
So let me phrase it the following way, so
we know that children are actually born
with the ability to perceive more sound
differences than adults can and so we
actually lose perceptual distinctions over
time as we acquire a native language. And
do you think that part of what you're
seeing may actually be the outcome of some
kind of synaptic pruning that may take
place earlier on in childhood developments
as the end product. A related question is
do you have data on speakers of other
languages? If so, are there differences
for example, is the hierarchical
organization of phonemes different?
So for example, the placement of nasals
with vowels rather than with consonants.
And if not, what would you speculate will
be you'd be likely to see another
languages?
- [Edward] I think that that's a wonderful
question and one that we often hear a lot
about because it's one of the most
remarkable things about the acquisition of
phonological systems is their sensitivity
to language environment. And so, that's a
natural one for us to look at and there's
a lot of properties in the neural
recordings that we see that seem like
they're specialized for the English
language not in work that I presented
today, but in previous work we've
demonstrated that for example, you can see
evidence of categorical type of responses
to place of articulation cues like Ba, Da,
Ga those kind of sounds in the superior
temporal gyrus and that's one that we're
pursuing. So one. . . can we look at that
same distinction between Ra and R and L
sound Ra, La one that's very well formed
in English listeners but loses distinction
in some Asian language. So that's work in
progress.
But I think that the way I see it is that
a lot of the way the phonological systems
are actually organized is very much driven
by our acoustic sensitivities. And so,
what I would predict is that the major
principles of that taxonomy or that
organization that we found actually will
probably exist for almost all speech
sounds, but where there are these more
subtle distinctions and place of
articulation is a very good example the Ra
versus La distinctions is another one.
These are more subtle ones that are very
language specific. So I think we're going
to see a very nuanced kind of answer to it
where there are certain things are going
to be universally observed across
listeners of different experiences.
But there will be some refinement of that
basic organization and that will probably
be reflected in its neural activity
patterns.
- Okay, this one is about age of
acquisition presumably for doctor
Mayberry. “Given the great influence age
has on language acquisition, would
acquisition of a second language at an
early age enable the acquisition of a
third language in adulthood?” And another
one also for doctor Mayberry, “Do you
think you can use these patterns you've
discovered for clinical applications?”
- Regarding age of acquisition effects on
second language learning. We don't really
have a lot of research looking at if you
know two languages will it help you learn
three, will help you learn four?
Presumably the answer is yes, but people
are only starting to study this question.
The other thing about age of acquisition
effects in second language learning is
that they are variable such that how well
one can learn to speak a second language
depends upon the overlap, the language
families that the two languages are from.
And what seems to be a really important
variable in second language learning is
how much education you've received in your
second language. So it is quite possible
for people to learn a second language at
near native levels if they're immersed in
it, if they use it a lot and in fact some
second language learners their language
dominant shifts. So that they're more
comfortable in their second language than
they are in the first language as a
function of how much they speak the
language, but I think this notion of
polyglots and people who speak a lot of
languages, how do we tease apart
linguistic talent from actually just going
at it and learning a lot of languages and
becoming familiar with the structures of
languages so that you can learn them, we
really don't know a lot about that.
The second question in terms of clinical
applications, I do actually think that
this work has a lot of clinical
applications. I think that we're getting
to the point where we can characterize how
much language and what kind of language a
child should have by a certain age to
insure that the child is on an upward
trajectory for acquiring language.
Likewise, I think that same kind of
information we can use to see weather some
children are actually in jeopardy of not
acquiring language. And the third aspect
of this, although there are many many
more, is that now that we know that these
young people who don't have language are
in jeopardy of not having language at all,
we're in a better position to develop
crisis intervention so of speak. You know,
it's an emergency, somebody doesn't have
language we need to get them as much
language as possible and we can have some
idea of where we might start in that
particular kind of training but there's
clearly much much work that needs to be
done.
- And here's the question for doctor
Fedorenko that I thought I had in my hand
before. “Music shares many features with
language structures and texts, etc. Do
people with extensive musical training
show different responses in linguistic
regions when listening to or producing
music compared to non-musical people?
Would they respond to violation of a
musical 'rule' eg: key signature in a
similar way to how others might respond to
a grammatical error for example?”
- [Evelina] So let me start with the
second one.
So the second question is asking about
these violation of structure paradigms I
have been used a lot in studying structure
perception in music. So it's where
basically you hear sequence of tones or
chords and then there's an expected chord
or note with respect to your knowledge of
the tonal structure. And people notice
these, you can find markers of these using
both kind of electrophysiology methods and
brain imaging methods. And it turns out
that the kinds of markers you get for
these errors are actually quite similar to
what you get for errors when you
encountered ungrammaticality in language.
Okay, so that's part of the evidence that
people have used to argue for overlap
between language and music.
There's a big problem with that line of
work and some of you may be arriving at
this already. And that is: there's a lot
of things that's shared between language
and music in these paradigms in addition
to the fact that they may share
similarities at the level of complex
hierarchical structure. That is you
encounter surprising events, you pay
attention, you may need to update your
representations, it's a learning event.
And indeed, whenever people have tried to
use control conditions to test for these
kinds of lower level violations like in
Stephen Kotia's work,
he often uses instrument change
condition. So the structure goes on as
expected, but you get a timbre change like
for something played by a violin instead
of a piano and for all of these
conditions. . . for that condition you
basically get exactly the same response as
you do for structure violation conditions.
Moreover, if you look at the responses to
very low level oddball violation, so this
is like high, high, high pitch, low pitch
or something like that very very dumb, no
hierarchical structure anything again, you
get a very similar kinds of responses. At
least in fMRI you get exactly the same set
of regions that react. So there's issues
with using evidence from these violation
of structure paradigms to argue for
overlap in some kind of a deep level of
shared structure or something like that.
There are some differences. . . again with
respect to those paradigms there are some
differences between musicians and
non-musicians but it's certainly the case
that just like we've known from behavior
ever since like the 50s, you know you
don't need to be a trained musician to
detect these violations very quickly, very
efficiently. But there are some subtle
differences you can report. Yeah, I think
I'll stop there, I mean there's. . .
- Thank you, so the next question is also
going to be a question merger and I'm
going to give this question to you David.
So the first part of the question is,
“Since many sign language users have some
degree of hearing ability, is there
significant influence of the local spoken
language on the structure or the sign
language?” And the second part of these
question is, “What's the nature of
dialectal variation, geographical
variation of dialect in sign languages?”
- Okay, the first part influence of the
surrounding spoken language on sign
language. I would divide this question
into two areas. In terms of individual
vocabulary items, lexical items, there's a
huge amount of borrowing from English in
ASL just for individual words. There are
many words which are conventionally
spelled, there's a manual alphabet A, B,
C, D and you can spell any word written in
the Latin alphabet with this manual
alphabet.
So that is one, it feels sort of like, in
a way, a foreign element but most ASL
signers also know English. So a lot of
things are finger spelled. However,
there's another way that signs are created
by borrowing from English and these have
been known as initialized signs where you
take the first letter of the English word
and use the hand shape from the manual
alphabet and you get whole groups of words
that way. So I'll give you example, this
is the manual alphabet for M two handed
sign, this is mathematics, A algebra, C
calculus, G geometry, T trigonometry, S
statistics and so on. So you get a whole
family of signs that are borrowed from
English. The movement, the actual
articulation and so on is native to ASL,
but the hand shape is expressing the first
letter of the corresponding English word.
Needless to say, this suddenly gives you a
huge potential for additional vocabulary,
but the way the question was worded, the
structure of the language and the
structure of the language in terms of the
syntax, in terms of patterns within the
lexicon, in terms of the phonology all of
that is indigenous and quite different
from English really very different from
English.
Now there was a second part of the
question.
- [Roger] Dialectal variation.
- Yes, there is dialectal variation. There
have been studies of that under the rubric
of the socio-linguistics of sign language,
socio-linguistics of ASL. I'm not familiar
with most of that work, but it does exist.
- Thank you, so the next question is for
Ray Jackendoff and I really like the
wording of this question. The question is,
“Does antagony recapitulate philogyny in
the brain and evolutional language?” That
is should we think about. . . is it useful
to think about the earliest stages of
child syntactic acquisition as being
linear syntax?
- That's a question I ask my self all the
time and part of the. . . well, there are
earlier stages of child language
acquisition that correspond to even more
simple models of language, like languages
that can only have one word per sentence
and those are useful as well. So at least
the earliest stages of child language seem
to be captured by very simple grammars.
I've been having this discussion with
people working in language acquisition
about when you can detect real syntax in
child language either in perception or in
production. Production is always way
behind perception, and I'm getting a lot
of blow back from them. But on the other
hand, most work in language acquisition
has presumed that as soon as the child
starts stringing words together that there
is syntax, that there are nouns and verbs.
So there's a lot of negotiating that has
to be done between this program of
research and the people working on
language acquisition before we can really
answer the question.
I would love it if we could show that
there's a stage of linear grammar that we
can detect in child language acquisition
that would be really nice. There's a
famous old book by the great Roman
Yakubson called child language aphasia and
how do you translate [foreign language]
because that's a--
- [male] General sound--
- . . . general sound patterns something
like sound laws, where he's suggesting
that what children. . .the order of
children's acquisition parallels the order
of loss in the other direction in aphasia
and this corresponds to typology among
languages. And this hypothesis, if we want
to say about linear grammar if we take it
really seriously, is like Yakubson on
steroids. Now I'm prepared to back off
that, but it's something that I'd like to
know about and this requires really
mastering a lot of the child acquisition
literature and convincing people in child
language acquisition that this is a
question worth taking seriously, and so
far I haven't really succeeded in either
of them.
- This question is for Mark Aronoff,
so. . .
[laughing]
They're very exited, it's a good question.
So are you ready for this? Yes. Okay, “How
should we think about expressions like OMG
and LOL on Twitter” So should we think
about these as a kind of degeneration of
language that's going to continue or
should we think of this as something else
perhaps a general tendency toward
abbreviation and efficiency?
- [Mark] Yeah, so it's very interesting
because OMG and LOL are very. . . they're
complicated because they involve the
interaction of spoken and written
language.
So if you don't have a writing system, you
simply can't do that, right? And in fact
we know a little bit about the history of
those sorts of abbreviations, they
actually go back to biblical times. And
so, it was apparently that notion of that
interaction between spoken and written
language seems to. . . rose with increased
literacy in particular among the creators
of the biblical text. And we know this
from things like verses where the first
letters of lines of poems will spell out
words and things like that or you'll have
poetry that's written in alphabetical
order and all that relates to what David
was saying about, it depends on what your
resources are. So now that we have writing
as well as speech, then we can actually
play with the interplay, the interaction,
between the written and the spoken
language right? I think as a general rule,
you could say that talking about language
in terms of degenerating never gets you
anywhere. Though I must confess that I had
originally written down a question which I
didn't submit and the question was WTF. So
thank you.
- Great, so next we have a question for
Carmel O'Shannessy now, and the question
is, “What factors predict how much do we
know about when a language combines, when
it draws on multiple different source
languages, what factors influence what is
drawn from one language versus what is
drawn from the other language?”
- [Carmel] I wish I knew the answer to
that. Sorry. There's a language with
similar structure except reversed spoken
in North America, Michif, which combines
Cree and Canadian French. And there, the
verbs are from Cree and the noun structure
is from French, so it's kinda like the
opposite of Light Warlpiri. And the
argument for that combination is that the
verb structure is so complex that you
couldn't really divide it at any point.
And so, if you're going to have a Cree
verb, you have to have the whole thing. I
don't have the same argument for Light
Warlpiri. One possibility is that Warlpiri
verbs appear more complicated in some ways
in that they have several different
conjugations and so on in a way that
English verbs don't. And some of the
speakers in the community have told me
that they think of English as easy to
learn. And I think there's an idea of
using English verbs or creole-type verbs
to children because it's easy and people
have said they'll Warlpiri as they get
older. So I think it's an idea of what is
easier for language learning and what can
then be learned later, but I certainly
like to know more about typologically and
psychologically what might be involved
there.
- And for closing remarks we turn to Fred
Gage of the Salk Institute and he's also
co-director of CARTA.
- [Fred] Okay, my role in this is to close
the meeting and most importantly to elicit
some applause or thanks from you for all
the people that have actually done all the
work.
[applause]
- In particular I'd really like to thank
the chairs of the session for picking some
really outstanding speakers, this has been
a great learning experience for all of us.
But also, I was really impressed we do
this a lot and the questions that were
elicited from the audience were really
coherent. Maybe it was the way you guys
phrased them. But it was very very
coherent and really quite wonderful and
some of the the best answers to the
questions I think only come when you have
good questions that are being asked. So
thank you guys for all of that, thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪